welcome everybody to the h3 podcast here
with living meme is that how do you feel
about that I don't know you told me to
give me life I mean meme dumb well
whatever he's a fascinating guy a mogul
I mean really an interesting guy I have
to say how old are you 22 22 years old
have has achieved quite a bit in terms
of business so point tonio you guys know
you guys definitely know me I like it
and I really appreciate honest of you
coming here good and joining us and of
course with ela kleiner right up
represent and we have one sponsor today
thank you
- Vince Aero more about that later
god bless thanks for joining us dude I
think it's I think it's great that
you're willing to talk we have a
colorful history yeah you know what
though it's like I don't like have any
like personal issue towards like someone
you know talking about someone else
I think it's really fun and like it's
interesting brings out more value out of
like what we do
you know that's the whole point of
making content for a true reason behind
it I agree completely and I [ __ ] love
that about like gum like Joey sells is a
perfect example like from the very
beginning we are [ __ ] on this guy
he's like a salad head but he embraced
it from the very beginning and like
really represented that attitude of what
you're saying it's like it brings more
color more texture to the whole yeah
it's a weird cuz have you met Joey in
person yeah yeah a smart guy is that
that was definitely is he's really
really motivated you know so you know
you got to respect the the hustler I
respect all Sonja all you pranksters
yeah like you the Bradbury's joe salads
you're all like hustlers in your own way
so what video which one by the way for
the record he they never claimed but
like they always they claim always
something real to me too so it's really
oh oh very nice and also let me don't do
the boys stuff is so I love so much they
keep saying no but they kind of laugh -
can we can hold it it that's what she
was telling as I find it so
like Joey told tells me that he called
them when we made our first spider-man
Elsa Bradbury video he's like yo guys
we're going could you watch our videos
yeah of course I watch stuff there buddy
who is the really funny cuz I you know
especially two creators they're funny
because creators know these creators
yeah right but at first like we had some
beats because at first we made this
video and you guys
it seemed that weren't happy with it
right and I can I can definitely talk to
that I'm not one to care about my
reputation it was just my partner which
I don't even like to talk about because
he really likes to be probably that's
totally fine I won't mention his name
out of respect for him because I know
that was an issue back then but when we
first made our Soflo Facebook page that
probably was almost two years ago now
which is crazy
or maybe new a year and a half you know
um we got em just like we got a lot of
flack from you guys and your and threats
of lawsuits from you and here and again
like I say this isn't for me
I don't care about the reputation thing
but at the moment in time we were trying
to we were actually in this point where
we're trying to take this page on
Facebook which was so for Antonio change
it to so flow and then produce content
which we produce a lot of content in you
know to get it to that phase changing it
having a good reputation around it so
you can raise money was important right
but again you know I'm like this guy who
you know my passion is not is not money
like money is great like it's it's fun
to acquire much of it but I'm really
driven with just going with the flow
being myself so if we're really grounded
person I'm not like it's weird like I'll
say like do crazy stuff but I genuinely
think it's fun to like just do that
stuff I don't just I don't have like the
steak facades I'm like a very open book
most people like they sometimes they
wouldn't want to come in here because
they don't want to be open book I don't
care like to me it's like why not yeah
probably a lot of Chris or no yeah of
course of course so what what is it that
you that you're passionate about with
like the Soflo brand like what is it
that motivate you um you know like when
I first
started like it would a plane was like
the video creation I clearly like I took
seven videos and they're pretty good
like I cut them and like for like a kid
you know what 15 years old pretty
impressive to like be able to cut yeah
especially with the software we had to
use that good day like I was using I
forgot it was like it's like video tie
like when I was like really like shitty
like free ones and no I remember I like
I got it all down and I was like oh this
is a good video like short people
because this one girl told me that this
kid was famous out of it there's like
back when like YouTube was like it was
big but like people didn't know like
creators was like a thing it just
started happening because of the
partnering to someone they had right
that when they first bought that and
that's when like people started getting
big having like a fan base and so I
thought was really cool and I needed to
make money other time so that's alright
I like we got me into it so at the
beginning you you well it seems like it
was motivated by just wanting to get a
job and make money that that and also I
thought it would be like really cool
they making videos i I mean things I
can't remember yeah my first thing it's
up there so like somewhere I put in my
Twitter it's like I did when I was a
little kid I did this like I took the
nyan cat and then I just like took that
like song and then I synced myself to
singing it obviously can't sing it
because it's really not so I had to like
speed it like the right time so what I
do is I put it slowly and then eyes and
I sped it back up and it was perfect so
that deal is it pretty well you know
files and views for like is it good I
don't think our first video got a
thousand views yeah I know over time
though I'd better get that thing over
the course I used to refresh it I was
like what 50 owes me three views are
like back in the early days when we made
videos like every time you go and
refresh it's just your own view you're
like spots that is sad you it has like
30 views and you know that probably all
of them are yours just going there
refreshing you got yourself and I think
you're getting views so back in the day
or when we made this video and you guys
were like album to see it for defamation
I'm just curious what was it that we got
wrong is there something where you want
is you're just gonna it's always going
to happen because people like if they
feel like they
you know their image was like negatively
impact they're gonna see that me
personally I didn't care what you think
we had it did anything wrong do you
think that we misunderstood something
you guys were no because it I mean like
I understand like why like you can have
empathy for people but the other day
like if you're just if you're if you do
it in a way where like people truly
think that you're not trying to make
them feel negatively about themselves
like does it like there's a difference
between like a of bullying someone and
like just saying like funny things about
somebody but like you truly like it like
you can be friends of them make them
know that you're just kidding about what
you're saying and not being a forceful
like me manner I think I don't think
your stuff is batteries it's actually
really funny and comedic 'el and also
it's sometimes you over exaggerate which
allows people understand that you're
joking around it's not just like
straight up like shots at somebody right
so I think that helps with in general
like you know you like act stuff out and
whatnot it's just funny right whereas
like other people I've seen there are
some people that call out are straight
up just like dissing people but like not
even like this I would mean like
straight up like finding flaws and like
people and it's like 9 hurt their
feelings
exactly and that's not I mean that just
makes you look really bad and it Paul it
can make me
aspic skin you know I was like not a kid
that was like I was like cool in like
high school whatever you know coming
from like status or I'm responsible
I didn't I like came from like Columbia
you know what I was like really young so
I didn't like D came from Columbia yeah
I didn't I didn't speak English so I was
a little bit like slow it's like that
kind of thing
what age were you I was like 5 so when I
I was in kindergarten we're a tiny
little idea yeah I don't know how I did
it interesting you just begin England
want to trade in the kindergarten I'm
yeah that's crazy I can see that would
probably be really traumatic as like yes
like even like third grade I was still
like this I came out like oddball
such because I went to a private school
and it was easier in public schools over
there because there's a lot of Spanish
and a South Florida but you know
came back on it I mean I feel like
sometimes you know the negativity makes
people incompetent who they are right
but sometimes you know all this
negativity and whatnot can actually have
make someone have really thick skin
because you I would leave like high
school I would leave my like my high
school you know from high school and now
go to like hang out with friends outside
of school who weren't influenced by
other people's like say I'm like oh like
I would seriously like I was like me
that person I'd be like oh they told us
not to hang out with you type of thing
so I've gone through a lot in that kind
of like sense but outside of like high
school like I was like cool I got a lot
of friends it was a lot of fun when I
went to colleges great experience but I
think it made me shape as a person a lot
and I'd never take for granted a lot of
things and I respect people are smart
all the times I like considered nerdy
because it's I was like friends with a
lot of them and they're like it's stupid
the only reason that they are like kind
of like what people might call like soft
sometimes is because they they're very
grateful people who have not been as
lucky because of the way that they've
been treated you know when people see
something different or special they
always point at it and they you know
even as like kayln kids always point out
at negative in a wheelchair they point
cuz they're like that's interesting is
the same like it's just a feel like
excuse me it's a psychological thing so
yeah so you really like as a kid that
you were you were different enough that
people were chose you I couldn't suck my
[ __ ] mouth because dollars don't live
out you talk to my spell is your thing I
also probably was like a weird kid like
or like when I was younger just cuz I
didn't speak much English you know yeah
so you got you had a rough time in
school like for how long um I'd say like
probably like middle school after like
high school it's like it was kind of
like I got like I didn't like it so much
but it was just like one of those things
where it's like I was still happy
outside of school I was one of the gym I
like other friends everything and like
it was weird because like the first time
I do
like middle school first time I went out
like it's like a party or whatever and I
met people outside my school and like
girls were like laughing are like the
stupidest jokes I might do like you have
no idea like I see the best jokes in
class but people try to not laugh to it
or make her laugh at me on purpose just
because like you know it's like they're
trying to be cool so like I always
thought was really interesting and that
made me feel really like grateful really
grateful like I don't know I think it
was a good experience I really like I
look back on it I really am happy that I
wasn't like a cool kid yeah interesting
yeah I feel the same way in a way like I
have Tourette's syndrome but when I was
a kid I had like I was at which he
[ __ ] mastered and Mike it was it was
a bit of a spectacle right but I think
it builds a lot of character as a kid
you can't go through school and knock it
like bullied a little bit and not rigid
it definitely makes you a stronger
person if you come out without being
like with egged on or bullied a little
bit right hmm I don't know builds
character it's important I don't I mean
it's the same thing when it comes to
like being spoiled and not being spoiled
you know I'm not a fan of like spoiling
your kids I feel like people have to
work for it even if it's like a
pointless thing like I wasn't able to
play like video games on the weekend I'm
feel like I was older you know that's a
child abuse it is pretty rough but you
know what it is though like it like it
really made me yeah I'm like a really
like I was like a stubborn kid you know
I always like fought for like my own
grounds everything but it really taught
me like how to build that discipline and
realizing what I didn't think I never
thought it was bad and I still don't
think it's bad but it still teaches a
principle discipline you know I don't
think like doing a little advocate it's
just the principal discipline and being
like you know like good kid
I read a study where it was like um kids
that can show restraint like if you put
a kid in a room with a snack and you say
don't eat this for an hour
mmm it was like a long-term lifetime
study on these kids like over 30 years
and the kids who are actually able to
show restraint and not eat the snacks
had way more successful fruitful lives
why did we see that I don't know I read
that sorry I don't the source but it was
like a really intensive study and the
kids who would just
eat it ended up more times in prison
like on drugs how many people I mean and
statistically I made a lot of people
maybe talking about like 5% more it's
not like they are all criminals no no
right but I mean like they must have
done this a lot of people ever became a
criminal yeah yeah probably like a
thousand there's there's at a certain
point like a thousand people is enough
to show guy after but I find I find that
common really interesting I think
there's there's truth to that I'm
wondering if it was from the Vsauce show
I'm looking at how was it be sausage
hell dissection no from the you thought
god we're learning [ __ ] from YouTube red
[ __ ] me like a TED talk on that [ __ ] you
know were you ever bullied in school I
was like not exactly bullied but I was
always so shy that I was doing only like
an odd one you know people weren't
really mean to me but I was like I was
just I had trouble like being part of it
again
yeah fitting and interesting so I
definitely had this like weird awkward
situation man yeah that's true
I was like watching like some like video
like yesterday I took a random video and
it was like like some call it like no
some high school prank or whatever and
they put like these like strings or
bungee cords I don't know from like side
to side on my blockers and like I was
just like okay I don't care that you did
that but the way that these guys sound
like sailing sit like screaming Yolo and
stuff like in the most ignorant way I'm
just like wow dude I would never want to
step into let's go ahead out here yeah
but like some people just like so
obnoxious high schools a horrible place
it's amazing that anyone get that I like
relatively normal like high school a
[ __ ] nightmare for anybody pretty
much and the 5% who were popular and
cool in high school go on to have the
like probably the most [ __ ] up lives
kind of right like they end up where
they end up with the shittiest jobs the
worst marriages this is obviously like
I'm talking on my that's what we all
like to think real movie posters hippie
stuff yeah yeah you thought you told me
that welcome this is why I like this
podcast in a way this format I feel like
in this country specifically right now
disc like obviously we've had a lot of
disagreements in the past and it's
really cool to sit in front of you and
just
see you as a human being and not just
like this [ __ ] guy on the internet
that I mean you know whatever no me
wrong like sometimes like you'll like
see someone on YouTube and they'll be
like oh that person's a character Lee is
kind of weird peppers it might actually
be lat you know way you know when they
you're out and about like you know I
really loved it just because it I found
it so interesting to meet people I'm
like guy I really enjoy meeting people
and getting to know them even if like
and in the things that it's more
important if you can do it without
seeking anything you're just just
meeting there's not they're not like
sound like an attractive girl it's not
like some like person that has money or
whatever you just genuinely are curious
what like that person thinks you know
that's interesting yeah I think that's
good advice too it's sometimes hard
because like I don't know well it's hard
to engineer your brain to not always
like want something as a result oh yeah
you're doing and just to like be with
somebody and be like I just want to
[ __ ] get to know you and not like
want something from you I'll tell you
something so I just recently and I like
this story because it's oh I was rolling
at a at EDC and I was like I was like
rolling friends that really oh you were
like on MD okay you know talk about very
good okay I'm verifier but I thought
over book no that's fine anyway so I
probably clarified because you're using
that Street lingo
crystal back bro how did you not know
Rolie duh no no roll any NDMA right so I
was also some friends whatever and my
friends like okay let's go find some
girls but like yeah let's do I not so we
like broke out some like a group that we
were with and then you know I was just
like I got tired and I was like really
in the moment and I was like dude you
know what I don't want to find like like
a like I just want to finally chill
personally a joke girl whatever no need
to find a girl that like that like is
like super attractive or you know like I
know that's what you want but like I'm
just trying to chill out right now no
I'm done with it you know like after so
much like walking around and everything
kind of just want to do it and you know
he like met this like one person for
like a cigarette and then I'm like oh
this person is pretty nice like it's
like
young girl smart nerdy could tell and so
I okay okay I'm gonna take her and then
the guy was like like he's like what do
you mean you're gonna take her with us
like I might do like it's okay like
she's chill like I don't want like
whatever it is you want and um he's like
he would like pull me aside like do like
this girl's like really unattractive
like what you do it like you did push it
but I'm like probably that's not what I
want right now like if you get it like
getting laid is one thing okay
like just chilling out hanging out is a
different thing and I'm doing something
different now so I took this girl
backstage and everything because I
actually bought two bands on purpose so
I could just like cut people like it's
convenient like if someone needs to like
go backstage no problem just hand it off
I hope they're not watch granulation
your head for life yeah but no I bought
two so I let her use it we went
backstage showed her it's like a trailer
then I also like took her like what
she's never seen the things that the
whole time she wasn't ever asking for
anything she was always going to flow
really really respectful and I love that
I think it's really I think you know you
could tell when someone's being really
grateful because it you just know that
they're not just saying it could some
people to it be like oh my God thank you
so much blah blah blah but it's just
because they were told to say thank you
they don't actually feel grateful right
so this person was amazing and I even
like do I even pay for like a helicopter
ride like back because I was like oh why
not because I I thought to myself like
dude how many like terrible girls that
like really hot but they're just
terrible people have I taken and like
done like spent so much money on them
and I it would be terrible if I don't
spend money on people who really deserve
it because this girl probably doesn't
get nearly as much as like these like
hot girls I like thing - this [ __ ] right
and so I did that for it was so I can
probably one of the nicest things I've
done and I have to think my one friend
Ally who's changed me so much my blast
six months because I was not that type
of person cuz I never saw that
but yeah so yeah so like are you still
in touch with her yeah you guys did you
stay in touch they like randomly texture
like yesterday I figure out how she was
doing because she has like
pretty like not so good pass she has a
schizophrenic mother who doesn't
remember her oh yeah so it's like one of
those things so it's like dude like I
don't know like it's a you see when you
go to these music festivals you end up
connecting with people and it's like
always like a like a meant to be
connections I was thinking what's like
you know you meet good people you help
them out I actually lost two phones out
there someone like actually robbed that
I was like damn do like you guys are
clean having good time right
that's really bad play yeah experience
I've been to a good one helicopter ride
back really bad so if we tried like
three hours how much is the helicopter
ride from you you went around 550 bucks
probably worth it to some degree from
agency like the strip yeah I'd say
otherwise if you take like regular uber
probably like 100 bucks but you're
saving like your radio or a lot of our a
lot of time and at the same time you're
getting experience right now obviously
like I think I took it four times so or
you know dev for it so that's a lot of
money especially if you're paying for
people but it's again it's like one of
those things it's like if you have if
you have the money to do it and you know
you may be and you can help someone else
why not
yeah but the most important thing is
gratefulness yeah
I don't care if the girls like really
hot really nice and really grateful
person I would take your - it's fine
yeah but you just gotta think it's
really beautiful when you don't have
anything in mind because I mean just
like everyone else I'm not gonna lie to
you and say that I haven't liked taking
girls like you know trips and whatnot in
like like hopes I like it's like oh I
think I'm gonna get with her so I might
as well like paste up you know yeah I
might yeah I got life no that's why I'm
open book that's the thing like I'm very
very like honest I don't really I feel
I'm pretty happy with my decisions right
so um we were at EDC because we went
there to make a video I found the
environment like really well we weren't
on drugs at a time we were there to work
which is probably was one of the reasons
why we I didn't really like it I found
that that environment was like super
intense feel like people were chill or
nice or nice don't really feel like that
well this was in New York it wasn't the
EDC yeah
all right we were at EDC Las Vegas was
all yeah but it was like it felt like
gnarly I felt like unsafe almost it was
you saying that your phones were stolen
doesn't surprise ya the energy was like
really negative like just a cloud of
like really manic weird energy yeah I
don't know it I mean have you been to
Coachella no Coachella is like it might
be like all like happy and cute and
whatnot but trust me like it's pretty
pretentious because a lot of people from
from LA
you know how light people are yeah very
very pretentious like where's your
resume type of thing I'm like no if I
showed you my resume you'd be impressed
and I walk away okay
it's like one of those things where is
it like Lily I feel like that's how
people are they expect you to show them
a reason to talk to alright then that's
on a lie saying I think you're from New
York right now I'm from I'm from SoCal
not LA okay but you you live in New York
I did live in New York yeah for you
people they're probably very pretentious
as well
pride stakeholder absolutely like just
like in a hurry
maybe yes yeah la definitely has a dude
like if you go down to Hollywood
specifically you find like some of the
most pretentious douchey people in the
whole [ __ ] planet like everyone's
such a trihard yeah you're you're
describing them yesterday oh it's the
worst too because the thing is that the
ones are the worst are the ones that
like they're like wearing like you know
chains or what doesn't matter like
they're just dissuading nice stuff you
know expensive stuff but it's likely not
real and even if it is by some weird
reason they do this thing where they try
to like push their ego on top of you and
be like oh my god like look at all the
things that I'm doing right and it's
like soda motivating because it's like
it's like you feel kind of like family I
didn't realize you know I everyone only
shows like they're happy pictures on
Facebook and then you get the press
because everyone looks happy and
successful but everyone has a shitty
life just like you it's just what they
present yeah and also when it's like a
facade it's also like more annoying
because you it gets you confused and
everything like say okay like a person
that
actually like has you know like a good
successful and whatever it is that they
are they they tend you know I'm not
hopefully to be a little bit more humble
because they know that they they they
are and they want to help people rather
than push it on top of them and that's a
better like way to look at it let's talk
about your Facebook page I want talk
about your brand so flow hmm like what
like I'm intrigued by like the facebook
business by everything you do because
you used to be on YouTube and you're you
but you don't really make youtube videos
anymore you're mostly on Facebook right
yeah what is this so flow brand you know
like I don't think it is much of a bread
anymore because I don't really push it
so much you know I have the license
content it's a lot of work you know I
have to constantly be you know hitting
people up and trust me I've like hired
licensing and it's not easier less just
license because you have to know that
people knowing that people get to the
good contacts but uh you know what I
want my brand to be is not as important
as what I want you know might might come
as a whole to go forward I don't really
care so much right now about the the
solo brand because it's just license
content doesn't really hold much value
so more focus on building brands around
like products you know my Karelian to
trying to get the e-commerce thing but
it's very difficult it's a lot of money
you actually have to hold inventory if
you want to let me know the commerce
you're trying to sell [ __ ] yeah so I
make products right but no drop shipping
right now so that's a thing few dropship
you can you make money and not have so
much of a lot of raffia what is that
like you you ship directly from China he
packets
it usually takes as low I mean as if
you're lucky as low as six shipping days
um but your business is whatever or it
can take up to like like maximum like 20
something to us like if you're unlucky
and then us the world it's like 30 or so
but rest of the world is used to like
long shipping I don't know if you've
seen like how long it takes like
some or something Amazon right like it
there nobody what's the business I don't
understand
so we refined products online that are
like going viral like we saw like the
black mass stuff we also did like the
bra this is like a while back that we
were doing those specifically the bra
the like that I don't know if you've
seen the the shop list bra that like
just sticks on and I knew it is okay so
we like got some models to come in and
then have them like try it on whatever
made a video saw a lot of other
companies doing it so we thought would
be interesting on like we take like kind
of like some like mini trends on
Instagram put them on Facebook and it
does pretty well you only make decent
money but it's a lot of hassle is
chargeback customer service issues so it
is a grind like I would say like if
that's why like I was telling you
earlier like the mineral stuff and like
you know advertising on that well first
of all you make money from facebook
facebook pays you right well not really
Facebook monetized some pages so flow
used to be monetized but then you know I
don't know they took it away this this
is when I was actually licensing concept
so they didn't have to pay you for
videos right and then it was why did
they remove it
um I think just the backlash of like
rebooting yeah yeah because like that
was like obviously like I was in a bad
light but I wanted to ask you more
specifically do you think that we meats
represented your free bidding stuff like
when we made the whole video about how
you guys were stealing videos and real
podium I think no but I mean definitely
were wrong about the the thing about
like that one account get them you found
out who that guy was right he works in
your office right he used to a long time
ago but he actually if you look at his
cause that's pretty funny
if you guys okay because I've noticed
this whole weird like what we called it
Facebook like wandering back then yeah
where it's like one page will won't
you'll be like so you have this one page
and you're like I don't free but I don't
steal [ __ ] but my friend here steal [ __ ]
and I'll share his page hmm like you
that's a thing that happens I didn't say
and at the time when you when you
brought that up though so
funny because like that I don't even
remember had I shared one of their
videos ISM yes yeah okay I think what it
was is I had bought a piece of content
from him and the deal was like I would
give him a share on top of like the
payment but yeah like but it was a piece
of content he didn't make no he made it
no he made it
there's the skies of content producer
okay good ticket it yeah you had other
channels with it like what the [ __ ] how
they're not sketchy channels i run of
like a non I claim have you heard of a
channel you should do well if you do a
call-out you give too much attention as
a thing I don't know what you guys catch
it yeah later
um this thing is a catch a cheater
I know oh yeah I love same guy no Louise
know that look let's let me go to edit
wait Louise wait that's good ticket it
oh my god no fun birthday well I had we
were in concept with those guys for a
minute after we made the video and are
you [ __ ] kidding me that's cazuca
dude that guy's got to come at me and
not say that that's him so you guys know
each other well I met this guy at
YouTube space a long time ago he's like
hey like you're so floating I like to me
love and then I liked guys number
whatever and then we contacted later I
was like okay you make content make
content for us his stuff is like not
high quality but it's like the craziest
like most stupidest stuff so it's funny
and it works well that's small because
it looks so it is high quality Facebook
content okay okay
can't even download the the that might
be like if I download my own videos yeah
like I reload my stuff all the time I
don't ask you and you when you click HD
you can't even get it like 1080p or
whatever it really hits it's weird
Facebook's intercept tell me what's the
shadiest [ __ ] you see on Facebook
because I I look at Facebook and I see
it to me it looks like a total
[ __ ] of what it seems like
supersize Facebook you know I'm a huge
Facebook's it well clearly I mean well I
don't know if you are not personally but
your business has thrived there yeah and
it seems like there's it's like
unregulated when I scroll figure just
for my personal side it looks like a
total [ __ ] skin
looks like a scam it looks like an
Indian newsletter that the end is like
send money to my Nigerian prince I get a
total mess like what some [ __ ] you've
seen on Facebook let that he wait like
so weird is like stop I've seen um I
don't know you know I can't like I mean
most I've seen a lot of like annoying us
advertisements like let's paid for where
it's like people like making so much
money on sort of things like ty Lopez
model but for like e-commerce because I
always get that because they know like I
go on Shopify and all that kind of stuff
but it's just like it's there are a lot
of those like ads were like they are a
little scam ëcoz like it's like why are
you making ads about making ecommerce
money when you can focus more on your
that business when I don't matter that
kind of less on what wait you're not a
fan of ty Lopez aye Lopez know it's like
you talk about the money that you make
but you make more money from talking
about of course when he's selling him
Jack dorso virus but I feel a lot of
those on like rights right I don't see
that many crazy things I mean I know
there's a lot of hackers are like you
know living in like Asia like something
like a lot of like people on Facebook
from like Pakistan and Philippines and
some of those people like they are like
that their stuff is like low-quality and
like they somehow like they do like some
hacky and stuff but overall what purpose
oh no I just like they just get on
peoples pages in this hack primer and
I'm like like pages and [ __ ] like what's
for what purpose you know just to get
like some pages and I love that there's
a whole hacking operation just think it
likes you know why it means followers
here yeah I thought I felt like spur
valuable on YouTube but it hasn't gotten
that bad yet um oh my god back in the
day when like you can actually like a
video on YouTube and it wouldn't like
influence like the growth that was like
the good times now on YouTube it's all
about clickbait it's all in consistency
you're how to be consistent with like
your uploads and then that way you like
slowly rise to the top and like now
you're like number one suggested no
matter what you throw up yeah well
what's the dip because you you started
on YouTube why do you think that you
were success more successful and
Facebook
than YouTube well I think I've made at a
time okay right when you called me on
everything I was not making any money at
all well a billion views a month zero
dollars really so yeah no seriously all
my money was coming from from YouTube
the only paycheck I got from Facebook at
a time when I was by the tide was 16 K
which was for like a billion views a
month they're like 800 million views a
month and so because they kicked me out
of the program whatever I don't know so
in reality I wasn't making much money at
all on Facebook all my money was still
coming from YouTube for a while the only
reason I decided to retire from that was
because I started trying to do brand
deals with my facebook and I was making
some good money but we're talking like I
mean like even with like the big size
that I had with all my stuff you know I
was grinding hard to make 50 K that
month and our expenses got to like near
40 50 K a month on production on
employment all the other stuff you know
so it got to a point where we actually
lost a lot of money just because it a
media business has obviously take on a
huge risk in terms of like how much
money is spent versus how much margins
you make you know they make a high
top-line revenue but a very low margin
on profits so that being said like I I
really like it was not easy and Facebook
wasn't exactly they didn't become my
thing because of the money it became I
think is I just enjoyed the fact that
you can reach so many more people I was
doing on YouTube and I was grinding my
ass off and again like we were talking
about earlier YouTube is really
difficult with the odds and it always
has been right so what was it that you
saw in the long-term potential cuz
you're grinding you're getting all these
views on Facebook but you're not making
any money but clearly you're doing well
now right you're flying helicopters you
going to eat not really I would say I'm
just a I'm a I'm a I'm terrible fighters
right i I would say that mean you spent
a lot of money are you been I defended a
lot of money a lot more than I should
what do you spend money on flights I
mean I took two two months off traveled
all of Asia
went to Dubai I like Dubai still like
Asia better because like the people are
like so chill but yeah went to UK that's
I've been spending a lot of money on the
travel adventure stuff I don't know I
just like I feel like that you play
poker - right yeah yeah gonna take me
that you like poker I play I yeah I used
to play a lot of Poker back in the day I
but I took some [ __ ] heavy losses boy
and I was like I can't do this anymore
like man and that was when I was in
college like I was living on like
student loans at the time so my colors
because I do crazy stuff on poker it's
crazy did it well there's something like
only one or two percent of players are
actually profitable over the course of
their their like time playing poker
I was definitely one of the losers man
it's a brutal game you have to play for
so long yeah you have to believe I will
the true successful poker players are
like mathematicians dude they're like
patient and it's a grind for them right
it's not like this is like trying to do
there's straight-up crying just like
it's annoying when you sit down another
table and they're all grinders because
you're like okay great at the way for my
perfect spot to get this person by a
hair yeah exactly and that's what they
do that's how people are successful
playing or you don't have to beat the
other people you have to beat the house
rake because when you think that the
house is taking five to ten percent off
the top of every box every fairy want to
type well like over the over the course
of the other game maybe because if
you're shaving off like five dollars
every land I mean like the way so the
way the way that they do it is usually
like at a casino it'll be like like $8 7
based on dollars it depends on how many
people are sitting down maybe it's 8 and
then you know the higher the the bigger
the game you play the better the odds
are for you because the houses are going
to take the work is is less by 4 yeah no
it's not less but yet by proportionate
like how much money you're playing yeah
but that being said you know you can
play big games at a home game and they
can be like oh yeah the rake is five
seven percent and it's it's stupid like
a person actually you know grinds you
can't grind you you would lose to the
house you can't beat that high percent
it's actually yeah over time it's not
does it make sense you are you losing
player or you a winning player probable
really
- what well I mean you get understand
like I did a pat is it like a do look at
it as a profession or like it's just for
fun no for fun for fun I would I mean
I'd love to do it but it's like it's wet
with anything in life that you like you
know that you do for like work and
whatnot you have to have like some sort
of end goal that you're looking up to
and as much as I like to win like World
Series and whatnot great right it's
still not like one of those things where
it's like I wouldn't feel so fulfilled
like if I just like once I'd done that
like I feel like I need more I need
something else so I still like the
business to uh you know work that I do a
lot but I you know it's hard it's hard
to stay focused considering like I can
just go travel right now and it'd be fun
you know do you think that you have a
shot of winning will surge poker I mean
playing I really that will shot but do I
have a better shot than like Phil Ivey
definitely no Phil Ivey though that
you're comparing yourself to one great
tournament players well no I'm just
saying like a good a good player in
general has like you know that he could
have a hundred times better chance then
like even though chance is a huge factor
in tournaments like them you can't just
say well it's a good player no like you
need help when you go all-in you need
love yeah so like Phil Ivey who's like
the best tournament player of all time
let's just say if compared to like
someone who's just an amateur player
maybe he has like 100 times chance
better of winning but still probably
like half a percent chance of winning
the tournament or something like that
I would say like someone that's like an
amateur would have like very very close
to zero a chance and look if you look at
the odds so if you want like your phone
and just go pocket aces every single
time and you take your starting stock
and you go to like the the winning stock
first of all your chance of winning like
with pocket aces against like a like
whatever hands like 80% let's say or 70
something that's depending on hand
you're not going to you add those like
if you multiply itself right that's how
you find the probability you multiply
0.8 one like 10 times however many times
you need to double up to get to the top
you're looking at a very low chance of
winning even if you have the best
starting hand just when it all in
recently right so it there is a very
interesting thing but play for players
can do it and it's just picking their
spots really wisely and taking risks
where the where they should you mean
picking spies and which hand to play
spots us in like not just hands because
a hand like yeah sure like when you're
preflop that can can be considered a
spot but I mean like if someone calls
you like I mean they're a someone let's
say some bets into you and you're you
think about it you're like I could call
I feel like I could hit my flush or
something you can choose to call there
you know thinking that you know this
first I'm sorry hand or you can choose
to back away thinking that the first
time is another hand you know you you
choose where to do certain things very
wisely as in like even though like it's
a 50/50 for you for like a 45 655 you
end up going and taking like though the
right route right a more conservative
thing because you think that over time
that's the right or the statistically
correct thing to do right other think
what there's a lot to it too they know
like good poker players look at the pot
and they're crunching numbers like a
Rain Man yeah forces like so much
enjoyment out with your stock sizes
right I mean like you're not going to be
like oh like that person blinked uh went
when he was hard not stupid you know
what a lot of the things are random but
yeah there's a lot to it and I think
it's interesting because you learn to
analyze risk without actually having
numbers in your mind like clean cut all
the time you just kind of have like a
center like a sixth sense to like
knowing whether you're good or not based
on the range of hands you think the
person would be playing in this spot
yeah it's complicated it's got to tell
me like we should don't do the spot of
the spot before I move on I something a
fun my next poker losses there we go but
I do have one question like well how
much money are you in on poker would you
say are you even are you close to even I
don't know I don't think I'm down that
much I'd say like over like funny
because I obviously pay
under age if I say I play this long
unless I was playing in Florida but I
think over like was it in three years
I'm probably down 50 down 50 this is not
bad but I've done a lot from up your
income bracket I was like we good but
for a regular gambling I'm probably down
the same gambling what are the gambling
do you play regular like you know like
baccarat blackjack but you know I've
come up to I don't know at the idea I'm
not like - like mad about it because
it's like one of those entertaining it's
like I yeah I mean is not worth that
much but still like we're also going to
get the same exact entertainment for
cheaper yeah yeah
gambling is a [ __ ] did [ __ ] median well
when I was in college I used to I I won
one tournament with 500 people took me
12 hours played online there's a lot we
did I won like $5,000 very good and then
immediately afterwards
I fell [ __ ] like a million bucks same
night I took that money to a cash table
the byun was like like five ten but it
was no limits and it was like it was
alright it was a good game and I was
like cool I got five thousand I'm
feeling gravy sit down at this table I
fly I died I had like pocket jacks flop
three of three of a kind
no Ezra and I it was a flop like the
other tough work do you remember just
roughly what you know yeah I know I was
I was in the lead for the nuts yeah I
had the nuts and then this guy calls me
with like pockets hands he's got nothing
on the board
I think catches a 10 on the river and I
lost all my [ __ ] money and like 30
minutes of winning that tournament which
was like the peak of my poker career I I
hit all in and whenever Ethan will play
and I will watch and sit with him
whenever he goes all-in and like I'm
dying that one day well I heard I know
you because like I see there's some
people I do take like the girlfriends
and wise and like they're just like
they're just watching old time and I
don't know how much they know about the
game they probably know enough yeah it's
still like what they go hole in GC so
it's like look you guys like quick
yeah yeah well yeah but like that
crushed me that crushed me to tourism
and like that was at a time when I had
no money I was on a loan dude I was
grinding I was like waiting tables I was
broke and that put me on a tilt and I
remember I deposited like a thousand
dollars after that to like catch back up
you know this gambler gamblers fallacy
and I [ __ ] went to a cash game and
the same thing happened and I lost like
a thousand dollars and and I had like I
was super I didn't play poker since then
I'm lucky that had the presence of mind
to be like this is [ __ ] up what I just
did thousand dollars for me was like the
world for me back then no I mean that's
a lot of money yeah my husband and 1080
kid yeah that's a lot when I go play
poker like my losses don't usually get
that high right like only like when I
play big games but even then like it it
stings even if it's like 1,000 that's
still life [ __ ] of her we had hurts also
like I don't you're doing it like for
fun like you like it right yeah you're
not one of those what's been grinding
forever and so like you don't care
because it's a short-term loss yeah you
know for you it's a really long time yes
that was a life long so I remember being
at like this realization like man I
can't play poker anymore
but like I think some people wouldn't
confess faced with that yeah that's when
gambling addiction stars in a path to do
no horrible things one of the good ways
of like standing up and this is it like
people will tell you no you do stand-up
earlier but the way I do it to like
really like get me like to stand up from
any table is when you've lost enough and
the things that you want to buy in and
in a way that you're not you don't you
don't bite you don't get into this
position when like you're like broke but
let's say like you have like $10,000 and
that you're willing to spend then maybe
you want to join at a table for like
four thousand four thousand two thousand
like is the case you lose them all and
because you're okay with spending like
ten let's say that's okay like sizing I
would say because then
you get to you lose all that you're
going to get to this point where you
realize in if you keep sitting down
you're very very unlikely that you're
going to make that ten back yeah so
that's like one thing that helps you
like stand away it's like when you get
to that point where it's like you know
what even if I can see you're playing no
matter how tool did I am about the fact
I want my money back it's just not going
to come back yeah so that always helps
and that's why it's important the size
how much how many bytes you'd be willing
to lose right yeah all right listed this
spot yeah so we'll take a quick break
we'll do a [ __ ] sponsored Shh me
Marino here if you want to use the
bathroom or something go enjoy it okay
you know say no so we have let me see we
got here we can just play chess not only
for the next hour I don't know we don't
have a lot more time because okay so
flow at 5:30 so thank you to our sponsor
today Vince arrow Vince arrow is this
really great watch company that sells
like high-class watches for just over a
hundred bucks this is actually a really
nice watch usually these kind of watches
like this is [ __ ] beautiful good
these kind of watches is just how bad is
this for you right now no no I just it's
over 100 bucks is a good deal look at
this watch dude that's actually
beautiful like other brands you know is
so anything like way more expensive and
it's like this is a good quality usually
it watch like this cause that have you
feels every day it looks at me we take
this plastic off ball here these are for
women
yeah I like the girl boy look at that
[ __ ] that's a classy ass watch no this
is really close here give that a feel
dude feel the girth feel the weight on
that [ __ ] so let's fill this one this is
actually really likes Trump wow it's
really good yeah that is over order so
this Lisa start at just over 100 bucks
but I don't think they go over $200 but
they're legitimately nice watches cut
out the middleman material you get save
visit veni vidi vici we Came we saw we
conquered so it says like well I mean II
that's what it means oh really learning
we were learning through water watches
here he'll and that enjoy it the more
you learn the more you earn that's right
it took stylo paralyzed right thanks
Doug
so this is like a leather band super
nice front here
vince arrow dot-com no it's vince arrow
collective calm /h 3v int e ro
collective calm /h 3 if you go to their
website right now you get this classy
beautiful watch leather wristband can
you can you it please observe the beauty
of this watch you get 15% off they wrote
here build your legacy today I don't
know if I will go that far it's just a
wash after all but it is very nice
I don't know if this is where your
legacy begins but it is a very nice
watch what does that mean veni vidi vici
we Came we saw we conquered that's all
on that it's just like there's a lot
packed an about that's a lot packed in
it sounds nice right
they mean vidi vici anyway you guys are
headed to a wedding or Bar Mitzvah
always with the bar mitzvahs and you
want to look slanting hot ghetto this
one's really legit another way if I saw
that every girl would be like there it's
really lit damn girl you want go on a
helicopter ride well let's go let's go
baby
I'm definitely going to be wearing this
though when I go to events it's huge so
if you guys are in the market for a
watch and you want a slamming hot classy
ass watch for an affordable price and
you want to support our show helps a lot
go to Vince the go to Vince zero like
the collective dialogue slash notes is
collective I kind of infused okay the
url's a little confused on be honest
collective why is it a collective
tribute collection regardless it's not
collection then cero collective Ben cero
collective calm / h3
link is in the description and should be
spammed in the chat is it being spammed
in the chat do um yes knife was already
there guys appreciate you that's a
really nice wish that's like you have
that guy
here's mighty Snipes the like oh it's
not out so whatever check out their
collection that they have a bunch of
really amazing amazing stuff free
shipping 24 month warranty
nice apparently they have three thousand
five star reviews I don't know where
those reviews are but I believe it
because this is a nice a swatch all
right I'm going to I'm going to take a
quick break
I'm going to the bathroom get a cup of
coffee we will be back in eight short
two minutes
don't go anywhere thanks for sticking
around we are back and ready to slam
here with so Flo Antonio I'm intrigued
I'm really chilly by the facebook shift
how does your business small work now
like you you don't steal videos anymore
um right now like how do you select
videos how do you put [ __ ] on your
Facebook page do you take [ __ ] from
people still how many people work for
you yeah honey it's employees you have
that's a lot of questions that I won't
ever know
mom we have about 1000 yeah but we got
rid of like two recently because I came
back for my trip yeah and like things
were like not good because your laptop
is when you go away for so long like you
start to realize who's actually doing
this [ __ ] we got people being lazy
exactly um what is the okay dude there's
a little theorises Boozer yeah I love it
anyways so top secret [ __ ] though
if you a cure the guy said to see that
no this is definitely everybody like
probably special but I think it was a
Austin Fox my thing was post for long
you Carol okay so yeah no I mean more or
less right now we're moving towards the
the mid role like model or just like you
know monetizing through Facebook I I
look like I said I just love Facebook
they've been great to like creators I
feel but I'd only it only got better
over time
and then they'll that Facebook's been
bit great to creators yes because
compared to YouTube in the early days
you but it's completely different like
Facebook is just they have no like moral
conscious
they have like they don't care about
freebooting they don't care about
copyright I think they're taking a lot
more seriously now there's a lot of
third party claiming and everything even
like music that like is on our own
videos from a long time before that we
created that was supposed to be
royalty-free somehow randomly gets
claimed violate companies now they have
rights manager and stuff well they
better now that they're introducing
mid-roll share money and like Facebook
me see if there should do this if you
don't know the money that's going to be
in the licensing business so they should
have been sued a long-ass time ago
Facebook I hope somebody Sue's them and
I hate Facebook whenever we get our
video ripped off you have nothing to do
about it
I [ __ ] tried to send no but they're
hired like recently they hire like 3,000
or so employees and they all work with
up they said always to protect protect
people who are being like bullied or
whatever but no trust me most of them
work on like on copyright they would
they like stop the [ __ ] I don't know but
they beat up the [ __ ] out of like their
their copyright seem like they so
seriously when I we someone reuploaded
one of our warm it up video and extent
the [ __ ] and cease and desist a DMCA
and it never got removed yeah except
keep giving me a dead end like on the
DMCA process it was really unintuitive
horrible and I just got impatient I
never took it down so there's people
making money out there hand over fist by
stealing content and [ __ ] right and it's
[ __ ] up and I shouldn't go on for
years and I think though on the face
when Facebook again like copyrights been
getting really crazy and yes if you want
to talk about selling content just go on
Instagram Instagram nobody make more
money on Instagram but it was the same
thing on Facebook for the longest time
ever since they brought on the the
monetization stuff that's when people
start asking questions obviously and
that's when like Facebook start taking
it easy I think they take it pretty
seriously and they like done a lot of
things and you can't just get away with
it on Facebook you will get strikes and
taken down and now if you use a video
every time you get licensed for it
so right now I've been recycling my
content for like the longest period of
time and recycling like um does that
work yeah it works can you enjoy solid
video prologue colony or can you imagine
on you to be uploading
videos like that like that's why I think
Facebook is a [ __ ] that's right but
don't like no quality control their
horizon if we recycled our videos that's
what I'm saying just reposting for
months our old [ __ ] like this of neither
that's not like that's not like
indicative of a place for quality I just
one video I got like 40 million views
and then I took it down because we
filmed it and the lady didn't like the
fact that we didn't blow her face when
she signed and said that it was okay
interesting
and then we blurred her face and then
alligator got even more what's up [ __ ]
oh my god such a trash website I hate
Facebook well okay so now you guys are
making money now you have the mid-roll
[ __ ] and you just showed me a screenshot
oh I'm not gonna say who it was no but I
can tell how much I don't
okay I want no I have to say I have to
say it's Carly it's like $1 CPI was user
setup
almost okay I use your imagination I'm
not gonna say who it was what does it
matter
sorry at $1 CPM you pretty much saying
that you have to like do some basic
basic arithmetic mmm
a little bit less the one dog but by oh
really show me a screenshot of 50
million views which you get all the time
on Facebook you see that [ __ ] like Joey
salads camera it's [ __ ] coming out
[ __ ] gets 50 million because there's
no quality color it looks like a breast
feeding yeah it's just you know sucking
ass - it'll look really cool I feel like
why don't you think of brevity like like
channel all it is is like best meeting
versus homeless guy best see here it is
it's a suit but it's probably selling
and that's ignore you that's the kind of
[ __ ] that does well on Facebook
so anyway Antonio's show me a screenshot
of someone who had 48 million views
approximately and made like $45,000
$45,000 from some shitty [ __ ]
Facebook on it down because the Facebook
reviews are like 25 cent watched a 25
second average watch time I thought you
just crawl in this concert of you right
yeah that's crazy
but uh well yes yeah overall like how's
YouTube though isn't like the how
naughty my yams are you - it's okay
how much of the CPI Monday's magnetized
well before the ad pocalypse like I bet
a really range per channel right and for
a video at best we would get like $3 CPM
but there's no go it was great for us at
the time that was like in December of
last year
yeah we don't yeah those December I had
the best yeah I know back in the day
though some people are like no no it
still happened yeah I was going to say
their channel to get 10 the Disney
Channel super brand friendly a great
brand friendly bloggers vloggers no I
think the Jake brawlers is it all come
on seriously yeah yeah they make is like
making like totally and it all come on
ten thousand dollars there's no more
like a hundred thousand dollars per
video well I don't know hmm yeah maybe
you mean a fast ten million views yeah
maybe boom you guys thought goes well do
you think did well I'd say out of it
there's like a lot already I already
made fun of them well look they're not
doing anything well I like that video by
those pretty but it's things like that
wait the audio jungle pick audio jungle
the part where it's like the little
insert like you're making fun of like
the music but wasn't at you you said
that sounds it sounds a lot of jungle
[ __ ] yeah yeah I know jungle yeah I
don't know jungle exactly I'm in the
music video there's like a part which
sounds like it was ripped in everyday
bro you're talking for jungle I don't
think that I was actually but that's so
many I don't know I watched so many
videos it was funny
but you know what the other day like
they are killing it yeah if you get hate
for it known I would let anyone in the
spot like at their age you know no it's
insane I'm not hating that for a
cigarette their success it's just it's
funny and I like the opportunity to like
punch up you know because these days
that I mean there's not many people like
super successful who are deserving of
getting [ __ ] on
usually it's like you find weird [ __ ]
and you make fun of them and that's not
as fun or like it's not good sport so if
I can find like Jake and Logan Paul who
are getting like 300 million views a
month and I can take a [ __ ] on them
I get
punch up I don't have to feel bad about
it so are you friends with any of the
pranksters or not really I'm Mike by the
way all the words yeah I still talk to
the bad days Joey salad and even to you
they wouldn't say that it's real then oh
well let's see Joey's like this hair is
really honest about things and funny
it's like comedic to me but no you know
they don't they don't like they like to
keep on a house even but like the ones
that can feel it the most is about a
granny they'll never talk about it I
don't carry would they kill me no
they're really good people they scare me
did you you all went on like a boat Ohio
is always a great man I love seeing you
on a boat I was like what the [ __ ] but
you're sorts what they are addicted to
gambling
there is soda really the Bradbury's what
are they playing a little bit worried
where would they loved it they just
something that just on that phone wait
wait I remember a scene when you were on
that [ __ ] boat and you're like I just
lost 3,000 I'm pretty sure you like my
book and I was like saw flow of a
gambling problem okay really I think
maybe it's possible I went up like 2k
and I went down like - that's all I
remember wasn't too much it's like small
it was my first time ever ever gambling
like gambling gambling that not poker
just saying yeah I've never done like
real and something I thought I thought
was so low Joey told me they cook if you
gave money I liked extreme it's like
getting really yeah you wouldn't do it
the most and then he got lucky
Joey told me like because I was talking
abut that you were going to come on
stuff and he was saying like that you've
used his content and not giving him
credit or paid him she texted me today
Joey was like throwing some some bomb he
said no but he does it he was
immediately a bad bad way no I'm sure
you guys are cool cuz he likes ice of
yesterday knows that ever IV that's why
I was on the phone them he texted me
today he's like dude why did you try
cutting me in a video I just came out of
ten minutes ago
I don't do the posting I don't do it I
saw you credit him yeah and then like
that post so then we fixed it but that
does happen means my editor
my publisher messes it up sometimes like
I'm uploader
I like shares people I share right you
know like get ship or shares with like
shake page it's like no been Phillips I
don't know if you're like Facebook okay
well anyway we do share for shares and
then we have like people that do the
video uploads so that's an actual job
the shares to Google it was the only
thing we share for sure so I know that
Joe is waiting for some money right you
know and I'm not even that much I wish
it was a lot you know how much it is not
yet because I've got it yes baby I Joey
told me thousands of dollars I wish that
just miss between you guys bye lovely I
love this whole like oh hold on video my
radiation hold up from video my ization
the last month and a half we well last
month for sure I leave me like five
thousand under my job really really yeah
so ideally he covers some selling
products and everything a job [ __ ] but
even the mid roller thing enjoy was like
Joey was like he license my [ __ ] and he
doesn't pay me and he owes me thousands
of dollars
let's go over it up because I definitely
a little a bit sad that much because we
got paid we get screwed over so much we
were talking about it today we got like
that they just took away the
monetization existed before the
suggested video today today was the day
they removed it so no one can make money
from suggestive videos anymore what does
that mean suggest yeah what is that man
on Facebook there's suggestive videos in
the carousel and like the little thing
where you can swipe up into more videos
the third one or second ones a
suggestive video you get that's a page
placement so you get paid however they
stopped the sharing of revenue for that
one is that like after you finish the
video yeah yeah yeah if you finish the
video usually scroll past it based on
how much time they watched your video
that that becomes the ratio of how much
you get paid based on like how much
and watch it yeah okay we got jelly on
the phone good too much chili are you
there oh yeah I'm not on the show
yeah you're on with self-love I'm on the
show it's live yeah it's live everyone
go hallo me and Joey Sally
alright at a meeting you idiot it you're
muted listen I mean I'm here with so Flo
and I was saying and I was saying I was
passing it on for you that he owed you a
couple thousand dollars several thousand
dollars but he laughed he laughed he
laughed over several joy you're dead we
got screwed on my citation you know it's
not that good so so he laughed when I
said thousands and he's like maybe
hundreds talk about like I'd say like
telling it tell him this remember a
while ago when we had our deal he had a
similar deal with op TV the Moni G
brothers they got paid out a few
thousand dollars and I was like where's
my money you're supposed to pay me out
as well and so froze right yeah I got
any money wouldn't pay you anything
you're right you're right you're right
good old feeling I'm gonna go back and
look at how every time Joyce hold on
hold on hold on so it's our old yield
stacked on the new deal that's fine
you'll get paid no way how long's right
is right we a long time ago we did this
deal where two years ago I'll do years
ago in my home hold on hold on hold on
hold hold I know that let me explain
what happened on there easily let's hear
Joey today so let's get to the bottom of
this we know we were paying people out
like 20 what was it 25 percent of the
revenue it was like 25 right yeah so the
licensing deal was I would tag them to
us I would give them 25 percent or I
don't know whatever right but what
happens to us is that we didn't get the
website because they took it away or
something I don't know we didn't
actually make money that Joey sells so
we'd have to pay out of pocket we didn't
actually make money but we thought that
because they obviously wanted to make
money why why did everyone else get paid
out but me I'm talking about two years
ago yeah I know that you were the last
one to come on board and we are less or
less the least views I think at the time
I forgot my videos will get we're going
up
same exact time there's work and I
remember they got a payout because I was
talking them about it and I hit you up
and you kept on telling me buyouts
Kuhlman payouts coming as in last minute
we tell me all the sign of money and I
never got to pay out and over the years
I let it go and I moved on and then I
worked out this other deal with you
which would probably be hundreds of
dollars oh yeah much but I still want to
get paid up they know that I just know
back then you owe me a lot of money when
I what happened pull out it I'm confused
you were playing people out even though
you didn't make money big howdy right
anywhere he promised how did you
calculate what you pay them because
based on CPM percent right so I paid him
always see less than what than what was
expected like I calculated the numbers
and I was like oh they were supposed to
make this much but we didn't get paid a
single dollar like it was terrible at
the time you know I was still you know
is like a year or so ago I was still
working my partner and everything I was
like okay well what do we do with these
people because I want to keep their
videos up and I want to delete them and
so we decided to do is like still family
I think like Joey I think we pay like
Kobe like do you believe this story
I don't know go in and now they make
great points they make let's say 100 to
300 dollars every million views so I'll
go throughout calculate I'm sure I don't
know how many of you I got on the so
flow pages but I mean I could go and
check and see how much about estimate
how much I would get but I'm just going
to run message it down anything at all
this stuff
Joey why do you years ago why do you
keep agreeing for him to use your videos
I have faith in him and that's so hard I
just hope one day I will get a doubt
video from two years ago we posted three
million news hold on Joey Joey you know
I'm going to pay you out right so much
I'll pay you out you're won't calculate
the couple hundred won right if that
one's easy to do and then we'll figure
out the old one by the way I didn't make
any money on it so on contract I owe you
zero but it's a good-faith we did that
good way to get us koji you can add
Denis I don't know if I paid Kobe or
debt whichever one does Dennison like
Octavia some of that ask them I paid
them out of pocket I'm not legally
liable that's opposed to you why didn't
you pay me out of pocket use my cell I
think no out with ten plus billion
followers with my videos and you made
money off of that exposure on your
channel okay
right but that's what I'm saying it
didn't make any money at the time but I
still paid people because I felt bad
because I structured a deal that I
promised people that they would make a
certain amount of money I'll be like oh
look it's gonna make you about this much
and if I show someone I think Omega much
and then it turns out that we make zero
not gonna be happy
nonetheless I think the reason I never
got around to yours was because you're
the last person and the money that was
supposed to come in would have come in
later and so we were hoping that we were
going to get the monetization right but
it never came through so that being said
you can look back on it we're at the end
of the year
you're on calculated outlet at the end
of the year I calculated how many views
my video has got on your pages
I remember I was counting because I
wanted to see how many views I got for
the entire year
but I don't remember that by the time
that you texted me when the heel turned
a million views came for your age 100
million well over a hundred million
views so what do you what do you think
that he owes you then for those views
again I guess if you had to guess I'm
going through honestly dude I don't know
because it all depends on if he was
monetize at the time and even if he
wasn't may still think I surely do
remember and you know you know many
followers you gain from that
how many closing I'm games going through
because I'm not sure I mean you can't
really check that but know well that you
can check that Joey enjoy you go I know
you can hold on well you got to remember
I never get report a full screen hold on
no you know they don't give rip they
don't give reports on like per video
business but I can calculate it out in
this and I give it on they give it our
monthly basis and we can judge by how
many views you got that one this is give
a payment
but listen I hate to see what you guys
couldn't talk I hate to see you guys
fight how can we resolve this take care
of it time I think it's not even that
much money because not that much money
Julia and even then even then on top of
it if you make any of it
Joey didn't make any money they don't
owe you anything there I always don't
worry else I can take care of you I
don't like people to be unhappy so like
like even if I shot it was even a
thought you were in the wrong but like
you really meant that you really wanted
something sometimes I go out of my way
to give something that I don't feel like
III agree with just because I want to
make them happy it's okay it doesn't
think they look at the end of the day at
the end of the day you got understanding
confuse off of my videos gained probably
hundreds of thousands of like Jedi work
and get paid out money said the videos
were making money and last minute I
don't get paid that's all I know that's
all I know what happened I don't know
what happened behind the scenes whether
you're being honest or not I let it go
at the time and I'm just hoping to get
the money for now it all set and in the
future would get better all I know is
I've actually multiple times that have
your good fortune I never did yeah no
dude joy like we we started like the
deal or whatever I think like way I
wasn't remember right you suppose your
videos without any like monetization
deal like the longest time and then you
said that hey look Weez we have to
change it up are you guys are gonna you
guys are take care of this well well how
much you gonna pay here all right what
do you think he's a couple hundred bucks
I guess you know I can look it up on do
bucks can you get some photo couple
hundred bucks for sure how much is it
share we'll keep trying
I don't know I tell them I'll I'll do
with no money if I get a few share a
couple chairs money I'll juicers with no
money
I wonder what do you happy forever peace
between you guys so weird so like there
was no money involved but if we can get
a couple of shares out of this maybe we
want to share one of ours for doing this
no mines that is overbroad yeah okay all
right Joey I'll even find the
conversation can I even
as I have to think with some chairs if I
wasn't getting money he's always like oh
I'll show you if you share this video I
don't do [ __ ] for shares not coming up
Emily I mean like some other kids yes I
actually know to be honest though Joey I
had no like I I completely completely
complete and I'm not in a bad way but I
completely forgot like I'm not like well
if I if I remember if I was outstanding
that with you I would have come back to
you and touched about it but I
completely true so I apologize about so
Joey are you happy do you feel like you
got it off your chest are you happy with
the resolution here I'm happy I wrote my
trust that's good you he was holding on
to this did you have any told me this
over the phone you got to do it in front
of all the cameras that are gonna be
like dude this guy to the baby would
[ __ ] it was like you had a great talk
this was not planned by now I want to
get to the call him yeah everyone it's a
calling I mean I was like that's a great
I know same book I told you like I don't
have anything to hide like okay my pod
doesn't like you know has to do
something to do so how many shares for
to get this right for you Joey is it
shares to make up for the deal but I
never saw phase four yes no stairs no no
no for the old one I told anyone I
there's to be square with everything
okay well in my of that well how many
calls you got no twelve Nellie well hold
on hold on although I have I have a has
like 80 something million on my phone
back on your phone yeah I manage a lot
of people and I still pay like monthly
fee and they all don't want to fight
people you have access to 80 million he
has access to 80 million Joe we're gonna
do a full pages they have like a million
and they got no activity somehow they do
come we want it just from straight so
floor do you not want the whole social
network okay Jeff little bro salad fans
they just don't know it's not your page
anymore so flow you say there's a lot
still my date all right so you okay so
yes he has 12 million followers on so
flow the page so how many how many
shares on so flow to make this right
I think five more a week Wow so is that
a lot of actually I'd like to read my
beautiful paper be fair though but I be
fair the new and repost your own [ __ ]
like people don't give a frank talk I'm
trying to I'm working for you Joey I'm
working for you well as well Antonio's
like five is a lot but I'm saying nobody
gives a [ __ ] because he's saying he
reposts his own videos and the people
they don't even notice right they even
notice so five shares over the course of
a week may not be a huge loss for you
so you said want Lisa one a week one
away one per week one per week yeah once
a week how about we do will do for that
way we do one month one per week one per
week they're not doing is that good for
you Joey that's fine I rule it Jake boom
oh good yo do it here this was like this
was really special that's just some
really special Joey are you feel good
you feel better
yeah good I'm happy that was okay I
really salad tomorrow dr. Jose will pay
the Sears is I'm going to be soon again
okay you guys go to succulent world back
together you you see my image you're
helping so flow out what is neck neck
Auto yeah the president said Brad brains
are still min behind I know by the girls
becoming I've been trying to get ahold
of the grabbers for so long they just
ignore the other numbered act like I
don't exist no ok give you the on the
line oh yeah well I didn't see why I
should say no to that
are you sure they're not going to
[ __ ] kill you were live on air right
now I mean I I want this to happen
listen um if you want to make mistakes
did I endorse it get him on the phone
yeah like you like people you take the
girl home excited tsunami did well what
are they gonna do I mean hopefully
because he's forever scares me if he
goes on a rampage was always an expose
we yeah I love small your net yeah are
you up to
I'm driving are you what you drove it
you know what
oh well Ethan wants to talk to you guys
and so Flo hey Moe this Ethan all of
that hey dude how are you mad and trying
to get ahold of you guys for a while but
I like you guys are real hard to get
ahold of I I can understand you don't
want to talk to me though I think
Ethan's bringing the world back together
no I love I just I I admire your guys
talk to one girl on earth what up dawg
I'm nice it's really nice to finally get
to chat with you like I I appreciate you
guys hustle I know like we've had our
gifts and gasps and laughs but I think
you guys are super I don't you guys are
hustled you're super fascinating people
I love to get the opportunity to talk
with you guys and meet you sometime
definitely better though
oh yeah yeah yeah on en la no yeah we're
in LA we have this podcast we've been
doing now we have so flow on and we had
Joey on and it's always like a ton of
fun let's get a roulette wheel in here
yo Chad I want that the prankster Cruise
reenacted live in our podcast studio now
yeah we're in LA but like I don't know
we just like having people in here and
just kind of like seeing them as real
people and not like internet the gifts
that we do so I think it'd be cool to
get to know you guys
that's another Rebecca what I meant
oh yeah dude bring it spider-man suit oh
yeah yeah we have a podcast it's called
it's called h2 pocket Joey was on it a
couple weeks ago you can check it out if
you want to get some idea of what goes
on here you guys people love me I have
girls in the bag dude we had girls in
the back yeah people like Joey South now
if we can make Joey sobs likeable I mean
come on you guys yeah yeah yeah we good
to go
well maybe the new you maybe people
watch our videos I maybe they don't
dislike you but they're probably like at
best impartial
I don't know why people look just like a
it's probably it's probably like the sip
ranks the fake pranks and maybe the well
maybe not disliking for the spider-man
Elsa ship more just intriguing because
you guys kind of pioneered that whole
genre right not just the pranks but the
Spider Man else's stuff thanks let's
[ __ ] no matter what
how does resin Elsa do if it comes like
he doesn't know what it wears out when
we love oh love I do of Indonesia every
time that she comes up you want to call
me later you wait six flags are you in
LA right now no I'm in England
oh yeah there's there's no that world
exists here in LA mo mo where do you
come in too late you guys got to do trip
too late it's been like a long time
alright that's so cool
Antonio you probably but go by until now
yo mo come to uh come to LA let's do
what a good cruise again
yeah passionately you don't sink into it
Mellie things really talked about it in
my group session so it's just like it
never happens but one day mo how could
you guys act like the spider-man Elsa
thing didn't happen I mean like I saw
the play button on the wall and your
guys's cars in the garage and like the
driveway which body man also everybody
talks about why do you do that it's like
you should have braised it it's a
beautiful thing yes we are equal living
in the house like pasta Liang don't oh I
don't know other people who did it hmm
so spider-man just runs in real quick
goes to say the dangers happy to live
there guys in your place I don't want to
get it cricket I don't okay sure
all right that's fair anyway I'd love to
get the chance hey mo I'd love the
chance to hang out and get to know you
guys I appreciate everything you do and
I wish you the best
thanks very much la panel it oh [ __ ]
yeah man I'd love fun you guys poop okay
all right dude drive safe drive safe you
know as you gone nice is he gone
Joey you just repaid your debt to me i
brokered the place between you and
Antonio and now you pay me back
immediately
that's why I left yeah those were your
buddies why do they deny it it's so
weird they should own that and so funny
I should totally own that but it's me
hold on we enjoy to say like it is so
funny like we're like fixing the world
one step at a time with our fake videos
did you guys used to say that looks like
we're helping so many people out we're
doing these social experiments they're
making people realize so many big lie
kind of interesting so what you guys
have this like good boy Joey I'm gonna
hang up on your ass okay yeah okay all
right thanks man appreciate it god bless
the jokes all right so that's the
interesting thing so like you guys used
to do these fake social experiments but
in your running like we're doing a good
thing for LA I was even doing the social
experiments that were like you know like
Oh like raise awareness he was but I was
posting them and like other other people
you fell enjoy a positive impact on the
world
well we're joking about it because it
looks like it's kind of like a shitty
positive impact it's like sure like you
can be a lesson but whoever the hell
listen and not realize that this is like
the fakest [ __ ] ever I don't know how
they fall it looks so fake maybe baby
you know that what so that's one of the
reasons I hate Facebook is I feel and
you have to agree the people on Facebook
who consume media are the most gold
elbow let me because you don't like that
for example I visit the Philippines just
a month ago now I love this beautiful
beautiful beautiful place they though
really look up to Western culture and
Western media they think it's amazing
they love Facebook really good people I
had [ __ ] love that place but it's
like it's [ __ ] like nice Mecca like
nice people but that being said because
you know they all speak English out up
there
what not like they really they find it
really intriguing they seem like the you
know the United States and everything
like they you know they just they never
actually seen it but they see it on
there on a Facebook and it's like so
intriguing to them because a different
American culture is Facebook media
that's not for a while so everyone's
running around doing social experiments
or like any and it's all you guys you
guys are nice sometimes I'll see my
family members in Israel share your
sharing soul flow and I'm like God what
the hell you guys say the problem I have
with like the social experiments in [ __ ]
is that you like and don't usually have
like a uplifting message but the setup
is something really [ __ ] up like
people stealing change of a homeless
persons cup and then the comments are
like man I can't believe I can't believe
people and you know it's a little thing
it's like so like the model is usually
to create something that's so
outrageously like stupid and like I'm
they are likely to happen the way that
happens is still also communicable
because the way happens it doesn't make
sense
like is that just being a bad person so
people are like you know like if you see
like the one with a cheater one that the
that a genocide or whatever for example
the that the dentist TV one with like
the Pikachu whatever what happened in
the one one were like the ones wearing
like a Pikachu costume or something but
what happens in it I don't know like
they catch like someone cheating and
like they're doing like some cosplay
like weird stuff like they'd make it as
goofy as unreal is it and you know some
you think that it should be obvious that
it's fake I don't think I obviously
they're trying to portray it that it's
not they they're not making a parody
they're making it seem like it's real
but I think it should be obvious
especially with so many people saying
it's fake like you like but not the
Facebook like ecosystem is different
like on YouTube I feel like every time
it's obvious and pranks have kind of
died down on YouTube as a result but you
there's no way to like reach our
audience on Facebook and be like hey
this shit's fake it's kind of
interesting to hear you say that because
you're sharing it you're promoting this
content but at the same time you feel
like if people found out that it was
fake they're almost were killed your
home
market um not really
you don't think so I don't know it's
just it's still freaking funny as [ __ ]
like to me it is yeah but for that kind
of stem a day I run a comedy value they
watch it because we're the top you can
actually do the [ __ ] bars where it's
like this [ __ ] will change your life
right
you think you invent invented uh was the
first one to like start actually
capitalizing on that it killed it and
then it bars I also invented the thing
everyone was doing it like their own way
like with black made black background
and white text I was doing it always
white background black text when I only
did bold right and yeah I had the Moses
when I first started but then I only
then I decide I wanted a punchline word
always on the bottom because I felt like
it was it would grab people and it works
however I still seen a lot of better
ones where they write out their own
thing but that was my signature I feel
like it it was did you invent it I would
I was in the first one ever cuz in
Twitter on Twitter there's still people
like putting like they did it but I was
the first we're not actually capitalize
on it right and back in the day a lot of
people that used to do like black on
black background white now you never see
that
almost ever you see black background and
white text it's almost always a white
background you have that signature black
text on white back that white text on
black background
yeah that's like a white background I'm
like to reverse it does it matter so you
in a way Facebook have to leave soon by
the way or you live do you have a ghost
story a ghost yeah that's a tough one I
don't know have you ever lyrical you
don't believe you down so it was
something paranormal a paranormal
otherworldly wait there was this one
time any but it wasn't to me okay it was
it wasn't to me um my my friend I used
to live next to a friend next-door
neighbor and they like texted me and
they're like dude Ian to come over here
Volvo and I wasn't there when this
happened but you know all of a sudden
apparently like there was just like
sleeping and
there passed out and this the the screen
door that were like the sliding like
glass door just cracked and it wasn't it
didn't sound like something hit it it or
I don't even know what it was but they
looked around there was no rock or
anything I hit it there was nothing I
was like freaked out cause I my dude
like what does someone come in like hit
your glass like signing door or
something or I don't think those things
just break but I was finally the
weirdest thing I mean I don't you
weren't there I feel like there's always
explanation something yeah that's a guy
so for me for me I'm just kind of like a
wave it off with like probably with that
but the weirdest thing was that about
you guys yeah so not really no I don't
like that just kind of I it's
interesting because we bring guests on
here and they sometimes have really
incredible spirit ghost stories and I'm
weird like non-believers yeah I'm the
same way I'm the same way like people
have told me like crazy stories I'm like
dude there's no need a filled fell down
like you you miss something or or like
if it's real quinces I don't like I
forgot what it was I've heard some
really weird ones so it's like oh yeah
like this happened to like my
grandmother or whatever and like
happened to my father's crazy stuff like
that I got come on yeah hop stuff even
like with the technology a technology
like involves that you realize that like
these ghost stories and all that stuff
trying to like die out it's like a lot
of fake ghost stories yeah but like in
general like you know maybe that people
believe it maybe it's fake but so then
they believe it it's real to them what's
the difference I have one last question
for you what do you think about like
because you said you think that this
[ __ ] should be obviously fake but on
your Facebook it's getting like 50 80
100 million for areas like what what do
you think about Facebook users dude well
I mean if you look at all them you have
to be on Facebook page right so yeah
yeah um if you look at the messages and
you read the messages of the people are
coming
it is like they're so weird like people
asking for like charity help all this
test out and like the way they type it's
like really weird like it's just like
you man
they typed terribly like they don't like
they don't they're not smart a lot of a
lot more dumb people and you think but
they're not you guys on dialer wait
they're not they're not necessarily
foreign like I'm not saying there for in
there like there's a lot of like really
weird like American people that like I
got message or whatever if you look at
the comments and everything the top ones
are pretty clever usually because the
ones at the top like if you read some of
the stuff like the long ones did they
chose what kind of person they are
yeah and you read the loved one it's
just like stupid or like weird that's
when you get to know like the kind of
people water that it's video base book
is a good representation of like America
of like the people who are out there I'd
say that I mean they have two billion
users now I think it has a really good
representation of the whole world and
some people are dumb kind of right yeah
more or less
they're just like dumb yeah I don't know
there's a little lot there's a lot
people are a lot more ignorant than you
think but why do you think people are so
willing to accept all this Facebook
content like the stuff that you share
and stuff like they're like this is real
and you see the passion in a common
older people that you know they don't
know that's going on they don't listen
to you know your your videos I don't
know a demos I assume it's mostly like a
24 hour that's right a 24 and then 13 18
the second it's actually the other way
although YouTube analytics are not just
for this all that's true that is a lie
hid yeah
yeah you have to be at least 13 our
YouTube channel or some toilet you can't
we have to say you're 18 otherwise like
is restricted content with your actress
so everything is kind of skewed towards
being over 18 and all the statistic
that's true that's why I like I feel
like your Facebook maybe a little bit
it's what I laughed when like youtubers
are like I don't have kids watching me
look at my demographic it's all 18 to 24
and it's like the real test is who's at
VidCon waiting for you when like when
you see Jake Paulo let's go
remember to survive again I was like
younger self a couple videos there I was
like I can't [ __ ] ever go there I
guess like jacob logan paul there and
it's just like hordes of kids dude
hordes of kids man well it's just like
in general like sometimes like there's
some having like all these like
influences or whatever
some of them are like very very
down-to-earth but some of them are not
you know and I don't like when they like
not down sir especially cuz I don't care
I don't care if I you have like 50
billion followers yeah I'm saying like
you'll have people I have less followers
than you think that they're more the
[ __ ] than you right and everything like
that that's not cool you gotta be done
sir
and so I don't like going also I feel
well even though I'm 22 I'm pretty
mature like I don't I don't like hang
out with people my age I often so I
don't really enjoy like that crowd to
they go out there and you know I think I
said I just do things that you know I
like to do I don't like it
well do it so you're on a flight where
you're off to Vegas play poker I'm gonna
play some poker yeah get in there shake
it up
what are you playing what's your game uh
I play well I'm gonna try I'm going to
play some tournaments to be fun but I
finally the vibes usually got a 1.5 K 2
K 3 K but I'm going to try to do the
main event but I don't want to do it by
myself well serious poker
the main event yeah which is what's the
binder that we get after it's a 10,000
but the things that you usually losing
almost on keeper say almost on your
brother you can make your money back if
you like make it into the money which is
a top 10% of the field let's say feel
doesn't like all the people playing
interesting but I'm not going to Paul
I'm probably not gonna pay for the whole
thing just because it it's very very
unlikely to be so profitable so I'd
rather have somebody like you know have
other people like your friends be like
old you want to throw it and they there
now I have a lot of friends that will
like the steak would love to you steak
other people know there they stable yeah
those ones that would like to not
because I'm good
but because they want to like fun it's
like sports better yeah yeah so like I
so when you play World Series of Poker
if you last till the final round that's
like a week long of straight playing
yeah yeah but I wouldn't mind and by the
way they also know the final table out
there which is like I do have to go
though okay was an amazing time I really
had a class dude it was we had a lot of
laughs yeah that was a gags never gags
we're had class that Joey sells call was
a real real momentous thing those foot
and nothing I told you like I speak
highly of a guy like despite or like all
like so that you brought a like the
the jackass videos that you used to make
was I get into them whatever
what yeah yeah yeah but he's a smart guy
yeah well so so khlo I brokered this
peace between you enjoy so I need those
if you don't do those four shares is hey
look bad of course of course all right
all right
thanks for coming as we all cross thank
you so much all right cool